à
[Musique]
ah ah
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
merci à ma cousine de temps
[Musique]
ce qu'on entend c'est son nouveau single
mon mais franck orsoni qui gueulent noah
merci m 2 est à tricoter viennent se
garer et qu'est ce que tu es et frais
j'aime bien leukemans salaires mais
aussi bien tu veux ça faire tu partes
avec tout de suite j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
à la chaîne regardée
mais là tout va bien et c'est vrai que
je l'avais pas ce que je t'ai vu en vrai
une fois qu'il est venu ici mais je
n'avais pas mais regarder les beaux
gosses c'est gentil beau gosse si je
vais rouge r non maître gims son nouveau
single c'est loin à regarder mais mme
mokhtari les comme how de voir m gibbs
ah oui tu veux lui dire bonjour
voyons tu veux quelque chose de moteurs
tu veux la cravate maître gims qui est
avec nous mais maître gims il a dit tu
as dit que tu rêvais de faire ce vol je
sais mes missions que j'ai je respecte
beaucoup j'ai toujours regardé parce que
je trouve le concept dingue tu l'aurais
fait toi genre si tu vas là si tu avais
pas percé si tu étais un jeune artiste
aurait fait the voice n'est pas aussi
loin
ah ouais ouais j'aurais kiffé je te
prête à tout - pour aurait choisi qui
toi t'aurais était donc l équipe après -
matt pokora jenifer quand elle était là
tu aurais été zazie florent pagny
florent pagny florent pagny ah oui pour
à la voix tétreault qu'il ya une voie
noah j'aime bien j'aime bien si je
t'aurais pas du tout fait rire j'aime
bien con mais ça vient ça il a fallu des
passes qui deviendra frère il a des
vestes europe a ni rappelées doit avoir
les écoute moi bien et florent pagny et
shaq fu chi minh bête mon frère il ya un
animal qui survole un truc dont le
gaillard laurent pagny barroso sur lui
un truc de ouf
bon en tout cas the voice c'était samedi
soir on voulait de débriefer avec toi et
on s'est demandé là dans la fois si tu
aurais fait un bond un bon juré dans un
rush tu penses qu est ce qu est ce qui
pourrait amener tout dans ce volet moi
je pense que il faut avoir un regard
assez spécial déjà avec candidats ils
arrivent ils sont stressés donc ils sont
pas à 100% mais déjà être s'en rend
compte
brett est sûre ils ont la voix qui
tremble at-touba charest donc faire
super gaffe à ce à quoi on peut avoir
des surprises qui stresse et wade
généralement pas ça dépend ça dépend
bien sûr c'est normal de stresser mais
ça dépend alors tâche est bien reçue
s'il a bien avec nous tu sais que tu
sais que je te kiffe c'était tranquille
alors tu sais quoi on va faire passer
des prestations 1 et tu va nous dire tu
aurais nous dira si tu te retournes ou
pas d'accord tu vas faire comme eux d'un
bouton ok ici juste le truc c'est pas
sûr que ça marche on essaye quand même
d'accord par exemple samedi soir il y
avait un bras selon le truc qu'est ce
qui te dois taper sur le truc qui fait
attention
samedi soir il y avait ma noah qui a
repris la chanson de rihanna man down
qui veut dire un mec était en d'armes
qui était pas bien
délire de ouf maître gims on va voir ce
bourg tournée au pas ses parts soit
sorti
[Musique]
payant
alors notre auguste s'est pas retourné m
gül qu'est-ce qu'on va dire pourquoi tu
te retourne pas aulas il ya vraiment
sont un souci de je sais pas si c'est ma
peur ou la voix tremble trop et perd on
sent qu'il ya vraiment ta pas qu'à moi
devrions ce total et ouais au niveau de
la voir nîmes après morceau et les
particuliers aussi mais bon j'ai pas
accroché maître gims attention deuxième
prestation il ya marvin qui chantait du
justin bieber on voit de suite retour
non pas c'est parti
[Musique]
je les morts
dia diouf
les formes
il faut
c'est
je ne
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maitre gims qui s'est retourné maitre
gims pourquoi vous être tourné parce que
il a une belle voix
ouais et je prends en compte justement
aussi le fait soit jugé il est là pour
être jugés quoi c'est un jugement c'est
un type comme ça je pense qu à 100% il
est à l'aise qu'une langue confiance je
lui fais ressortir aurait-il médicaux
pour qu'il vienne dans ton équipe
au lieu de voilà pour lui dire avec faut
que tu viennes lamboley aujourd'hui
écoute c'est pas un titre évidente sur
ton mode piano voix comme ça faut être
culotté pour faire ça comme ça et devant
des noms comme pagny et compagnie donc
tu es pagny compagnie sans renier
compagnie je pense qu'on peut aller plus
lente et pas forcément sur ton terrain
de base a choisi un titre mais peut-être
que ce type là ne correspond pas moi je
vois quelque chose je vois quelque chose
d'énorme je vois quelques mois le gars
je vois quelque chose de grave je vous
ai mis en tort aux hommes en équipe
[Applaudissements]
franchement être gay alors aux gens sauf
est ressorti troisième bon sauf un petit
3 on se retourne tac et ça se retourne
tout seul mais bon un peu de tri et ici
attention il ya quelqu'un dit c'est
partir là on y va allez c'est parti on
enfin
[Musique]
côté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m d'une ce retour est sur morgan bravo
alors maître gims ya mia mika et pokora
et matt pokora qui s'était retourné il a
choisi finalement mika hui tu kiffes lui
ouais j'ai bien aimé il gros via du
groove ya quelque chose et revivre des
anciens tubes des années 90 je suis pas
si tu vois ce que je veux dire dans sa
voix je vois sur la commune de mana toi
quand même plus en plus le visage du
type qui dit pas qu'il y en avait un
visage super doux super et d'ailleurs si
par sympathique et en chante des trucs
de rebelles genre le mec n'est pas
tranquille il est pas vraiment mais
s'accepte pas à l'intérieur de lui-même
surpris de la voir un signe majeur a
laissé les prétoires votre oeil on se
fait alors une petite gardien une petite
dernière à tokyo
écoute bien et tu nous dis si tu te
retournes ou pas c'est parti on lui voit
dans ma tête j'ai des chevaux lancés au
triple galop jeu sans battre mon coeur
de cette course folle dans amour tout et
j'ai la place aux larmes
et la sincérité ne me fait pas droit
[Musique]
notre guise lm voix touchante
c'est vraiment pas tu chantes non il a
fait chaud c'est ou non attendez d'être
une voiture jantes là quelque chose
une voix qui touche sincèrement non mais
c'est énorme et vous vous dites mais ils
sont parce que la musique c'est pas
forcément le fait de chanter juste un
les gens qui chantent plus juste sans
que c'est les chorales et son derrière
c'est vrai on regarde - chante juste
quoique une vague hier toi tu es là tu
chantes pas tu sauf si on me met
toujours en chorale c'est important la
le grain de voix et de fait de toucher
les gens avec eux tu peux chanter qu'ils
n'avaient pas de voix qui est je pense
que là j'ai reconnu annoncé
[Applaudissements]
non sincèrement il ya je trouve que
c'est la dernière fois que samassa m'a
fait simple c'était avec l'om
choqué le rêve un petit côté très
sensible comme ça on n'est pas dans un
truc théâtrale macha alors un sondage
lh2 dingue mais il ya quelque chose ou
bien il ya une proximité avec du coup le
rapt est retiré les lunettes parce qu'il
reconnaît pas les gens non mais c'est
bien du coup qu'elle a chanté peut-être
quelques estimations pour les chanter
peut-être sa carrière on se calme mais
trop dins mer sert à cause du droit
d'après noir sothys mac os x